leadership and management are part
science and part art today we'll explore
how we can prepare plan and execute
effective leadership and communication
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
today I look forward to speaking with
David Dodson Dave is a lecturer in
management at the GSB as well as an Alum
he teaches managing growing Enterprises
among other classes Dave won a GSB
teaching award and is a six-time speaker
in the graduation last lecture series
which is quite an honor additionally
Dave was an operator for many years
starting and running a number of
for-profit and non-profit firms Dave
recently released his new book the
managers handbook five simple steps to
build a team stay focused make better
decisions and crush your competition
Dave thanks for being here
sure that was quite an introduction I
wish my daughters were listening well
hopefully they will be you clearly have
spent a lot of time thinking about and
sharing ideas on effective management
your courses and book are full of great
advice
when it comes to interviewing you talk
about the importance of deepening and
narrowing can you explain what you mean
by both of these from a hiring manager's
perspective and what guidance would you
give and then for those interviewing for
jobs how would you suggest they prepare
for an interview that deploys deepening
and narrowing so how this all happened
was years ago when I was managing a
company I was CEO I wanted to be better
I wanted the whole company to be better
at hiring so I went out to the bookstore
and I bought all the hiring books that I
could find that I thought were worth a
darn and I told everybody you're not
going to see me for a week I literally
went in a room locked the doors and went
through about a thousand or so pages
when I used to interview I had this
question I would ask how do you know
when the refrigerator door closes
whether the light goes out or not and I
thought I was so clever with my question
and my riddle but really it had nothing
to do with the criteria of someone that
I was hiring
deepening and narrowing is a completely
different concept where you have a
specific score card in your and you're
concerned about or you're focused on an
outcome that you want and you've got a
series of questions that you ask that go
deeper and deeper and deeper so hey Matt
I got an idea let's just let's just try
deepening and narrowing okay I'm hiring
you for a head of sales you ready I am
you didn't think you're gonna have to do
this today huh hey it's all about
Thinking Fast and talking smart let's
see what we can do so this is for a head
of sales position so I say
Matt so what's one of the most important
things you do in the position of head of
sales oh absolutely motivating my team
great so can you give me an example of
where you did that
sure we implemented a competition among
the the sales team and how often do you
do these competitions well twice a year
twice a year okay and does it involve
the whole sales team the front line
sales folks not the enablement team I
see and when did you start doing these
contests about 18 months ago great and
then after you implemented the contest
what was the increase in growth rate uh
we we got up to about 20 25 I see and
how did you design that plan
well so a template was given to us from
Senior Management okay so so Matt we
could keep going but you saw that I
learned a lot just with that one example
right in a very very short period of
time including by the way that you
weren't the author of the plan that you
were just implementing the plan so that
might be fine but if if creating new
Innovative plan Innovative programs was
part of the job description I'd say I'd
say I probably wouldn't give you a plus
if implementing existing plans well it
sounds like you increased sales by an
addition incremental 10 but that's a
kind of in real life probably we would
have gone on longer this but that's the
notion of deepening and narrowing where
instead of you ask you know 15 canned
questions and you just strafe at 10 000
feet you dive in on a few particular
subjects and you start to build this
Mosaic where you really get a sense of
whether this person is going to achieve
the outcomes that you want so I learned
a couple things from this activity first
that I would make a lousy head of sales
and and two that you're you're a very
good thorough interviewer but what I'm
hearing is that as a hiring manager I
need to think about this notion of as
I'm asking questions I'm going deeper
but narrowing it down and really
listening to what the person is saying
and as an interview candidate man I
would have to prepare very differently
if I got questions like that versus the
way I might have prepared so really
useful information especially for those
who are looking for jobs one thing about
that too that you made me think about is
sometimes a student will raise their
hand and they'll say well that seems
like kind of a aggressive in-your-face
way to interview here's the thing the
best candidates love these kind of
interviews because they know that they
have so much to tell you and they want
to show off and they want to tell you
all the things that they're doing and
they don't want to be at 10 000 feet so
the best candidates eat this kind of
interviewing up
very important to understand and and
that means that we need to practice this
kind of thing and I think that's really
really helpful insight for sure you
rightly highlight the importance of
feedback in your book and you've
developed a six-step framework for
delivering feedback can you walk us
through these steps and provide an
example perhaps yes so in the manager's
handbook I lay out a six-part way to get
feedback because how we usually do it is
we kind of wing it and it's really
unclear what the point is and the
turning point for me was when I was
talking to Paul English who started
kayak.com he told me this story about
after he had sold an earlier company to
Intuit and he was the CTO at Intuit and
they were selling a company to Oracle
and they met with Larry Ellison and
afterwards in the parking lot they're
walking out and his supervisor said to
him Paul can I give you a little bit of
feedback and right there in the moment
instant feedback he told Paul about some
things that he had done that weren't the
way into it likes to do things and if he
had waited until the end of the year or
two months later even a week later that
that feedback would have been so less
important so I took that lesson from
Paul and into it and Larry Ellison and
developed this framework so it goes like
this first you start with the
expectations then measurement how you're
measuring it
the feedback itself you ask about any
obstacles you offer your support and you
make sure there's alignment so let me
let's say that you're the chief
accountant head accountant and it's
you're not closing the books on time so
I might say Matt our expectation is that
we close the month within by the 15th of
the next day okay right there I said to
you Matt what my expectation was and how
we're measuring it are there any
obstacles out there that are keeping you
from closing the books on time then I
say to you under support I would say so
Matt what else can I do to help you and
support you in getting the books closed
on the 15th of the month you can see how
that can be very conversational
but all six of those things are
essential if the person doesn't feel
like they have your support
they're going to feel like they're set
up to fail if you haven't asked them
what obstacles are out there they're
going to go out there and they're
thinking you know Dodson doesn't really
understand what I have to go through if
you're not clear on what the measurement
is then you're leaving it all gray on
what your expectations really are so
just walking through the six part
formula make sure that you checked all
the boxes and by the way Matt
once you do this a dozen or two dozen
times it just comes naturally you don't
even have to think about it Dave I
really like how you reinforce some of
the key Concepts we've talked about on
this podcast before that is having a
structure a structure can really help
you you have a six-part structure for
giving feedback and it's a very logical
structure and aligns very well with my
approach to feedback I believe we should
see these situations as an invitation to
problem solve so you're actually laying
out the problem very clearly and you're
showing that you support the person in
trying to address that issue but at the
end you're very clear that you have
buy-in that the change will happen I
really appreciate that structure and
think it's really important I'd like to
dive a little deeper into feedback one
very specific type of feedback that many
organizations employ is a 360 review can
you define what a 360 review is for
those of our listeners who aren't aware
and I'd love for you to share your ideas
on how to execute a successful 360
review the whole concept of the 360
review goes back to the US Army during
World War One when they wanted to get
feedback from an officer subordinates
to make promotion decisions I want
feedback from your peers and people that
report to you typically the 360 review
is not implemented correctly which is
that you use some you know the latest
app everybody answers some stock
questions
they're delivered to the person
uncurated oftentimes those are hurtful
comments and you don't really make any
progress
so when I describe kind of how to do a
360 process I talk about what I call the
three C's curate create a plan and close
the loop you take the information and
then you give it to either a third party
or the person's manager to curate that
information the idea is not to dump all
of the raw data on the person but to
look for themes so let's say then that
you and I were working on somebody's 360
and we found three or four themes and
that's the curation process the second
is to create a work plan so we're not
just dumping
on to you hey here's what we heard good
luck but here would be a work plan on
how you could address these three themes
and then the last thing that you do is
you close the loop and how you close the
loop is you go to the people that offer
the 360 feedback and you put everything
in one of three categories I heard this
but I'm not going to change because of
for the following reasons I heard this
and I'm going to make these changes but
I'm not going to be able to make these
changes right away because
and the third would be I heard this and
I'll be making these changes right away
so in closing the loop everybody feels
like they're heard nobody feels like
they have a right to demand how you're
supposed to manage or not and you've
laid out a timeline of when you're going
to do things and when you're not going
to do things 360 reviews done properly
are a massive competitive weapon it
seems to me that the type of 360
feedback you're describing the active
process there
helps people not only to improve because
you get valuable input but it
demonstrates clearly that this notion of
continuous Improvement quality feedback
is listened to respected and acted upon
and that can be a very powerful message
for establishing a culture that
continues to grow and Thrive exactly and
360 review you're trying to make sure
that you're not creating a culture of
apology we're all trying to get better
so the point is I heard this feedback I
really appreciate the feedback I want to
be a better manager each year and so
here's where I'm going to take this
feedback and improve
you know the the first time I did a 360
review and I got feedback they told me
that I had ice water running through my
veins because I was very cold and
standoffish yeah that did sting a little
bit but that was a massive turning point
in my development as a manager and I
realized that I needed to show my
humanity and my own personality and I
was withholding that because I thought
that's what professional managers did
had I not had 360 feedback I probably
would have gone a decade or more with
that ineffective technique
I appreciate you sharing your personal
experience with that I too have
benefited from 360s and have changed my
ways and I have to say I appreciate a
Winnie the Pooh reference any day in in
reading your book I was struck by the
notion that preparation is compassion
now you were making that claim when you
were talking about how we let people go
fire or retrench employees but it
strikes me that this notion of
preparation is compassion applies to
lots of things we do as Leaders
including our communication and the way
we interact with others
what do you think about applying your
notion of preparation is compassion
Beyond just letting people go and what
goes into good preparation so we can be
truly compassionate in my class at
Stanford we do a lot of role play role
play whether you do it in your head or
you do it with someone else is an
opportunity to try out different
approaches where the risks are zero so
yesterday I was talking to a CEO who's
going to have to let someone who knows
that they're going to be laid off what
the timeline is for them being laid off
and he and I spent four or five minutes
role-playing it and talking about what
her likely objections are going to be
which means that when he tests this
conversation with her later today he's
not trying things out Raw on her but
he's thought them through and he's
thought about what her perspective is
and what would be meaningful to her
that's where compassion is and also it
makes you a more effective manager
because you botch a conversation and you
might spend hours or days recovering
from that mistake when all you needed
was a few minutes of preparation
I like this idea of role-playing I think
it's really important and actually
speaking the words to somebody speaking
them out loud or just thinking it
through really important we know from a
communication point of view that
preparation really matters for both
planned and spontaneous situations like
you've described you have some idea of
how that employee is going to respond
but you really don't know and I love
just framing that as compassion it's
compassion for the other person you're
trying to make that circumstance and
that situation go better and that
preparation can really help yeah can I
give you another quick example of where
that sure let's say for example that you
have just bought another company and you
have a company meeting and if you
prepare it you can finish your remarks
and say now I was thinking what it would
be like for me if I was standing there
and one of you was up here and these are
the five questions that would really be
on my mind the first one is what's going
to happen to the health plan
and then you answer that you go through
all those questions because you're
prepared so people think wow this person
first of all answered all of my
questions but second took the time to
think about what matters to me
I really like that example for many
reasons it definitely demonstrates how
preparation thinking about how the
others might respond or the questions
they might have but it's also a really
important skill to have as a leader when
you were in a q a there are a lot of
reasons people don't ask leaders
questions none of which have to do with
the fact that they don't have questions
and so thinking that through
demonstrating that great example of
preparation is compassion
you make a strong assertion that I I
agree with you assert that to be
successful at work you need to be a
fanatical custodian of your time what do
you mean by this and what are the best
ways that we can maximize our schedule
and be efficient you know I stumbled
upon this study that was done by a
friend of mine and they looked at 27
high-performing CEOs they watched what
they did in 15-minute increments and
they acquired 60 000 hours of data one
of the conclusions was that they were
ruthless about their time and they
didn't use fancy apps or anything like
that or any tools they use just basic
time management tools I'll give you a
really simple example take your
30-minute meetings turn them in 20
minute meetings take your hour-long
meetings turn to 40 minute meetings and
I realized that that one change would
save me 70 minutes a day over an hour a
day and by the way there was an
interesting sort of byproduct to that if
you say that you have a meeting from 11
to 11 20 people show up on time they end
on time they get started they don't talk
about the weather and then add to that
the amount of time that we spend in
meetings every day I think it's 12 hours
a week and of those meetings executive
self-reported that 40 percent of the
time was wasted
I want to dive deeper in what you talked
about with meetings because for most of
us meetings are really challenging and
difficult they're often inefficient
undirected and lead to more chaos than
Focus I know you offer some very
specific tips for better meetings do you
mind sharing a few of those yeah so what
I did is everybody knows meetings are
broken so I studied people like Jeff
Bezos for example and how they ran
meetings or Steve Jobs and how he ran
meetings I harmonized those into seven
simple steps one step is when you start
the meeting before people dive in and
start discussing you go around the room
and ask for clarifying questions another
example is you need to make sure that
everybody participates and generally
speaking it's better to bring in the
voices from the least senior to the most
senior because if you start with the
most senior person there's a natural
tendency for people to morph their
position into what that person stated
which is not the way to get the best
information that's something that John F
Kennedy did he always called on people
in reverse order of seniority because
they didn't want people to get
influenced by what they'd heard from
someone else there's a simple technique
that the founder of General Motors used
to Summarize each meeting and once I
started using it nobody wanted to go
back to the old wasteful meetings
I love that you've codified effective
meetings and I and I like that you you
tested it out and and you're really
living in doing that what you talked
about preparation is compassion it's
thinking about how to do these things
effectively to save people's time to
make sure that you're efficient and that
you accomplish things I love that notion
of being mindful of status and Power in
the room and actively working to reduce
some of its impact by having the people
who might be more Junior go first and
it's it certainly seems to me that
planning is key in all that you you
talked about there so thank you for
sharing that often those very tactical
practical bits of advice are the ones
that our students really remember years
later
before we end Dave I'd like to ask you
the same three questions I ask everybody
on this podcast are you ready for that
bring it on if you were to capture the
best communication advice you have ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be it would be something I learned from
Peggy Noonan who was Ronald Reagan's
speechwriter she said people talk about
Ronald Reagan as having a great style
for speaking but what she says is the
most important thing is content and have
something to say worry less about style
and more about making sure that you have
contents something that's interesting
something that's useful to The Listener
so you're flipping on the head the
advice that we often hear style over
substance you're saying substance over
style who is a communicator that you
admire and why
the communicator that I've learned the
most from is one of our colleagues at
Stanford Irv grosbeck he's very
economical with his words every sentence
matters and he's got this affect about
him that makes you know that you matter
to him and that sort of clear simple you
matter to me style is something that
I've tried to model myself after Irvin
is wonderful and his students say
something very similar so the ability to
connect the ability to focus really
important in the way he communicates
question number three what are the first
three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe the
first one is you want to be very well
prepared the second is to think about
what matters to them we have a tendency
to think about what matters to us so you
have to imagine yourself as The Listener
as the other person the recipient of the
information the next is when you begin
your communication you have to connect
with them you have to give them some
reason to trust you and the last is to
make sure that they feel like they're
having a unique experience that you're
not just giving them the same
information that you gave somebody else
so I know I cheated Matt and I gave four
in there so we've heard before the idea
of preparation being audience Centric
making sure it's relevant I'd like for
you to expand a little bit Dave if you
don't mind on what can we do to to make
it unique because that that's a very
special thing that the notion of
immediacy and intimacy that you're
talking about what have you found helps
make it feel like you're uniquely
connecting with someone well Matt let me
use an example from our podcast
so we talked about the importance of
role play
well to make that a unique experience I
reference something that happened
yesterday a conversation I had from a
CEO yesterday so your listeners know
that they're having a conversation with
me that they've never had with anybody
else
bringing in the real world and what's
happening immediately or recently can
really help people feel as if the
conversation is unique and special and
not just a formula
Dave this has been fantastic you have
given us so much input and practical
advice that we can deploy not only as
Leaders but also as employees and
organizations the notion of preparation
the idea that we can be more efficient
in our use of our time and to really
think through how we give feedback
can help us all be more successful thank
you thank you Matt
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Michael Riley and me Matt
Abrahams for more information and
episodes visit
[Music]
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
Stanford GSB
foreign
[Music]